frank schneider sprechen wir auch jetzt
am morgen frank was ist denn der neueste
stand jetzt der neueste stand heute
morgen ist dass das jugendamt spricht
die stadt münster sich geäußert haben
wie es denn sein kann dass die familie
sozusagen fokus ist jugendleiter stand
aber das kind nicht herausgenommen
worden
dabei ist herausgekommen bis 2015 2015
das jugendamt schon kontakte familie hat
der hintergrund war dass der jetzige
haupttäter adrian v ja bereits seit 2010
im fokus der ermittlungsbehörden stand
erst mal wegen sexuellen missbrauch an
schutzbefohlenen das hat zu keiner
verurteilung geführt aber danach kamen
acht ermittlungen wegen
kinderpornografie dafür sie zweimal zu
zwei jahren auf bewährung verurteilt
worden
und das musste natürlich auch das
jugendamt und da bekannt war dass er ein
verhältnis hat er mit der mutter des
jetzigen hauptopfers das jugendamt sich
ein gestaltungen da muss man sich
vorstellen das ist das erschreckende hat
offenbar alle getäuscht er hat ja zu
diesem zeitpunkt der verurteilung eine
therapie machen müssen und hat dort in
der therapie und auch eben den behörden
stellen vorgegaukelt er hat ein problem
erkannt er arbeitet seine probleme
bekämpft seine neigung und die
clearingstelle der stadt so nennt sich
das das kinderschutzbund polizeigericht
jugendamt auch wirklich psychologen
dabei die haben ihn alle begutachtet und
das muss man sich vorstellen hat es
geschafft alle zu täuschen dass dann
2016 das jugendamt von noch losen
kontakt zur familie hat aber als die
mutter dann sagte sie lehnt weitere
hilfen ab da es keine handhabe auch vom
familiengericht keine handhabe das kind
aus der familie zu nehmen mit dem
argument man habe keine gefährdung
momente gesehen und das klingt natürlich
jetzt mehr als zynisch wenn man weiß was
den jungen danach passiert ist man sonst
muss man sagen es sollte jetzt natürlich
die ganz harte arbeit beginnt der
polizei weiterhin diese schrecklichen
filme zu sichten das sind über monate
wenn ich möglicherweise sogar jahre
dauern am ende alles auszuwerten und da
beginnt natürlich jetzt die polizei
münster weiterhin mit hochdruck weil sie
am weitere täter und potenzielle weitere
opfer identifizieren wollen und die
täter festnehmen und die opfer befreien
er ist jetzt tempi ammann zugeschaltete
was weiß man über den verdächtigen aus
brandenburg
also dass der heißt ein ritual der ist
kino wort gemeldet und ist in einer
kleingartenanlage vorsitzender vor der
ich jetzt gerade stehen die
kleingartenanlage sankt georg und ich
habe hier mit einigen kleingarten
nachbarn gesprochen er gilt als sehr
zuverlässig war zum beispiel immer dafür
zuständig dass er hier die die
stromzähler abliest die leute können
sich gar nicht vorstellen dass er
irgendwie sowas gemacht haben könnte
aber offenbar ist es so dass er noch im
april in münster war und einen
zehnjährigen jungen gemeinsam mit adrian
v missbraucht hat der info einwandfrei
identifiziert hat außerdem wurde im auto
von adrian v die adresse schon ein
ritual gefunden und das auto von adrian
v wurde hier in dieser region gesichtet
und die menschen in der
kleingartenanlage kann sich das gar
nicht vorstellen ein ritual ist auch
sehr aktiv in sportvereinen im
karateverein wohl auch trainer gewesen
außerdem arbeitete er mit seiner frau
und schichtdienst in einer pflege firma
in eberswalde und hat auch drei kinder
der eine nachbar von der colonia sagte
die kinder seien aber schon etwas älter
also ein einige noch einer geht noch zur
schule einerseits in der lehre und die
älteste sei auch schon im arbeitsleben